so we have the graph of a function right
over here we want to think about what
does the limit of f of X as X approach
as X approaches 3 appear to be and to do
that let's just think about the limit as
X approaches 3 from values less than 3
and from values greater than 3 so what
let's first think about the limit of f
of X as X approaches 3 from values less
than 3 so this little negative
superscript says we're going to approach
3 from below 3 from 1 to 2 point 5 to
point 9 9 2 point 9 9 9 so if we
approach so this is 3 right over here so
this is 3 right over here
and we're going to take the left side or
the left-handed or the left-sided limit
we're going to approach 3 from this
direction first so when x is 0 f of X is
there when X is 1 f of X is there when X
is 2 f of X is there when X is 2 and 1/2
f of X is at 5 when X is at when X is it
looks like you know roughly 2 and 3/4 we
get to 4 looks like about f of X gets to
4.5 and so it looks like as X approaches
3 from values less than 3 it looks like
our function is approaching is
approaching 4 so I would say it's look
it looks like the left-sided limit of f
of X as X approaches 3 is 4 now let's do
the same thing for the right-hand side
so the limit as f the limit of f of X as
X approaches 3 from values larger than 3
so notice when X is equal to 5 our f of
X is up here when X is equal to 4 f of X
is here when f of X when X is 3 and 1/2
it looks like we're a little under 2 for
f of X and it looks like we're getting
closer and closer as X approaches 3 from
the positive direction or from the right
side it looks like f of X is getting
closer and closer to is getting closer
and closer to 1 so I would estimate that
the lip based on this graph that the
limit of f of X as X approaches 3 from
the positive direction is equal to 1 now
we have an issue in order for this
to exist that we have to get the same
value as we approach from the left hand
side and the right hand side but it's
clear that we are not approaching the
same value when we go from the left hand
side as we do when we go from the right
hand side so this limit right over here
does not exist does not exist the only
way that this would have existed is if
we got the same value for both of these
and then the limit would be that
valuable we're clearly not getting the
same value